this is a production of Cornell
University
but you get to the eventual varieties
for gardeners website you go to
gardening cornell's edu or gardening dot
cils cornell edu both of those will work
and so this is the main page of garden
based learning at Cornell you go to
citizen science going to scroll down on
this page you see we have mental
varieties for gardeners links to that
that project and then we have the
vegetables variety trial gardens link
and their instance the lessons lift the
vessel varieties for gardeners in New
York State I'm actually going to open
that one right there and we hit this PDF
document so this document has been
produced long before I arrived 17 years
ago so a long time it's been coming out
here early and in around 2006 the
information we are getting from
commercial research researchers who are
doing commercial variety trials that
really declined and so we're trying to
identify a different way to get
recommended variety list for gardeners
so we decided to start asking gardeners
to share with us varieties that we're
working well for them and so that's
really how we initiated the vegetable
varieties for gardeners citizen science
project and I was infused as a six that
we created this website with some
additional funds
we've sent not on additional funds so
this is the functioning on essentially
no resources so it's a little
challenging at times but it still gets
the job done
- great varieties that are grown in New
York and come up with options to add to
that recommended variety list so when we
go we're going to come back to the
special varieties for gardeners website
but first let me go to 2017 design so
this is the design for 2017 and the
reason
want to go here because I want to
identify a specific variety
let's try black seed is Vincent so that
might be a variety that you're going to
you we're going to want you to tell us
how it did in your particular garden
trial garden firm actually I'm not even
a log into this yet I'm going to just
punch in Sisson and this is pine box and
hit search and see what I come up with a
spicy Simpson and this is a map of where
lady has been added whoa all right heart
analysis a little sensitive um so you
can see of these are ratings that were
provided in previous year and I wonder
patty be from Santa New York and
somebody we know I do think that this uh
Kay uh Cole I'm pretty sure we know who
that is in st. Lawrence as well and you
can see Cee Cee Cee Cee G um on a dog
other uh then a Debbie L was from Orange
County an MCC Oneida County and then we
have Claudia Claudia from rat looks like
Cortland I think and then Ron here are
thinking about a lot of people we know
because we have black students infants
in our variety trials for many years now
so we want um even if you're already
listed here or if you're not listed here
we want to teach adding to the reviews
so if you are already listed here and
you know how to get back to this account
you can ask your review of black because
Simpson its overall cumulative review
over multiple years you don't add a new
review by
year give us um too much data or us to
manage so it is a cumulative review of
laxatives Simpson over the life of that
particular garden we're going to
actually look at how you add a review
and you can certainly add a detail about
about what happened in any given year
but we don't do year to here's a
different review for each year and just
give us too much information so let me
go back to if you do not have an account
how do you set up account and that's go
not to register on registered with our
sites so I'm going to add a garden
profile here you simply fill out this
information and there is a required you
can see which items are required and I
think life some of those counties did I
would choose um if you have a
demonstration partners for your County I
would choose a demonstration garden for
that particular County if you would like
to do if you have multiple demonstration
gardens and you want to have multiple
garden profiles you're welcome to create
multiple Gardens profiles I'll show you
another option if you want to keep all
those profiles link but there is a some
limitation to that and so we don't
gather a lot of information about the
garden profile you want to be easy and
and not too complicated
not more information than we can really
manage but let me go back to the login
and so this is my garden profile and
over here you can add multiple profiles
I can add an additional garden profile
so if you wanted to have more than one
profile for your county you can put it
in the same I mean yeah more than one
garden be covered in the same garden
profile the limitation on that as I said
um there is one you would only be able
to write one review per variety you
don't try to have that level of
complexity so now that I'm actually in
there um as me
we turn to Rack feed and Simpson if you
ever run into a problem the best thing
because as I said this website was
created a while ago the best thing to do
is this log out and try to get in again
sometimes that corrects the problem and
we just make the best we can for being
pretty old website it functions pretty
darn well and again we don't have
anybody to help with this up we run into
a problem where we're a little bit
troubled so that's my Hugh Simpson and
um here you can share your review once
you have and here the review is very
simple the reason why we have these very
simple questions is because we consulted
with plant-breeding folks and when they
ask they do field trials with growers
these are the very basic questions that
they ask growers so we don't want to
make it any more complicated to collect
too much data that becomes overwhelming
for us there's so much noise when you go
into field trial that collecting very
detailed information about the practices
people are using isn't helpful to see
how the variety does overall you know it
becomes too specific to be useful so we
focus on these very limited ratings and
date you it's just for the glowing you
just if stars and in the review you have
a lot of space here you can elaborate on
how you're caring for me whatever you
want to go into you you know are you
using conventional practices organic
resin integrated pest management you
have ready says you're growing them in
container all of those details you can
put in your review as a way to help
people who are reading your reviews I
know it and when you look at some of the
reviews and Yelp am and they have like
got novels in there this is real freedom
retinol and you can also upload a
picture I'm going to try to upload one
you'll get this little separate box and
then you choose a file and I perfectly
to file rabid image that would work and
so if you get an error usually that the
image is too big and you have to open
the photo in and some Photoshop thing
and make it small but I see if you don't
get this thing that says whatever your
image is call has been uploaded then
your image is too big so I'm going to
close that and then my image in there
because I'm going to do likely to
symptoms symptoms I know it was going to
fit and I can always remove my image so
if you want to add a photo give that a
try if you upload one and it doesn't
work and then you can see keep making it
smaller it still doesn't work just save
and then get out as a whole program and
then go back in and you can see under
manage my reviews I can add I can always
go in and edit my reviews so for example
if I grow provider bushings again this
year I can edit my review of provider
voicings because I've grown in this year
and maybe have a different different
overall review of them and then I had
when I started and so I think part of
the problem here is here's the AMA
administrator so they're not quite
seeing what you see when you can edit a
review but you can just click on manage
my reviews manage my profiles once
you're in there I'm going to go over to
one more thing these top rated varieties
show how long how many people have rated
those reviews and the most reviews not
surprising we have 101 reviews of fungal
but be fabulous if we had hundreds of
reviews of all of the varieties that
really informs our selected list of
variety we also go back to the special
variety trial site if you haven't been
there to go there you'll see that we
have ma Fiona has uploaded much of the
mask you
for this project there one of the things
she did not upload it was the signage
you can use in the trial learn fast
timing is available through the Cornell
box folder which at least one person in
each County typically the county
educator have access to class counts
which you can download those signs and
manipulate them locally to suit your
needs and print them for yourself kind
of counting as a question how often do
you watch the reviewing so so how often
do I want to we want the ratings you
because of human rating if you I would
say you go in there anytime and put in a
rating for example uh I think I would be
able to learn I had something to say so
here on provider we see oh I found out
that this being is not it's not um
terminating well or I'm finding that
stealing are dying so I'm not having
much success rate with seedlings I might
go in there and just start the providers
machine review because I can always go
in there later at harvest or some other
juncture is not an add to the review
saying oh actually they even though they
are slow to get started in the end they
they did quite well so you can keep
adding here you at the very least I
would hope that you could go in there at
harvest and provide that review so
however it works best for you in place
you might find of just taking this
review you know the things that you have
to provide isn't it maybe you do a paper
version that several people maybe
contribute to and then one person goes
in and write the review so maybe use a
intermediate paper version is helpful
and this happens one person go in and
write the review at some point and then
our hope is that that you you once you
have your profile in there
from your County you will continue to
add to that so on - counties look at
them like superstars let's see can any
of you be an icon and they are reviewed
42 variety so this would be fabulous if
each county has 42 varieties 50 counties
have 42 varieties in there you really
would be the ones who are helping us
establish that list of recommended
variety and that's what we need you need
your help to do that because our
researchers no longer have interest nor
funding to review varieties how the
performance of varieties a length of
breeding varieties for specific purpose
and then the plant breeders might break
on the varieties that they're trying to
develop so fishing serves tiny faculties
in the area not a user name which would
you try again and is packed
should we keep using that or should I
create one Mississippi and Kentucky
Oh excellent question oh I think I'm
going to go back to you Patti
um I think you can go in there and even
change your name in my profile I can
actually change my name
for Lori - LJ b77 and then I think I can
update that so if you can get in if you
remember your the hard part is
remembering hello if you can get in
there once I think um you can change
your name the - thank you I've changed
my name there so go in and change your
name so here I'm hoping about password
recovery work so the main part is is
trying to remember which email do you if
you forgot your password but you can go
to recover your password
Venice's your email that you use and and
then it will sense that account and
hopefully still active account so the
only problem we've run into is if people
use them email that they didn't use they
don't no longer you
we can't recover your password for you
you don't have access to passwords so
hopefully email address recover your
account and then change the name to
whatever you think is appropriate and
it's okay to use the same uh I feel like
if you had variety trials in your
general vicinity previously to use that
same account would be appropriate even
if it's not that precisely the exact
same location but it's pretty pretty
similar because we're not really that
fine fine details here if you have any
trouble trying to get information in and
just shoot me an O or or Fiona and
children straight as you can
well we'll set you up because this
federal variety trial garden is is
really extremely important that you
provide us with this information so in
turn when we go when Gardner comes here
and it's nice to have more than six
rating about something oh look at this
one this rating Uncle Tom a actually
it's successfully uploaded a picture on
goal and so when pictures are uploaded
we actually is more than one picture was
uploaded it will show up multiple
pictures will show up across there and
you can see would be nicest this is all
just loaded up with reviews from New
York other states also like to provide
reviews both we care mostly about you so
I think this is a pretty exciting tool
oh let me show you a few other things
about this tool if you are logged in
while we're here and you're not seeing a
question so I love this so I'm it I
could be here for a while um we should
you put other things like I log back in
to do them all right when I'm one point
as long business balance account I can
um filter my reviews by my state
my free zone or my soil texture uh so
let's do my drop free zone so I have to
tell you about the cross free when
you're in the setting up your profile
and there's a link to like the back
cross free map
really is broken we have to fix it but
again I told you that's hard to get
things fixed when we don't have a
programmer but there was that oh now I'm
seeing the variety based by only
varieties that are reviewed and in my
frost free zone so I can limit my search
that way and and then if I typed in
something like some ID or crop it would
limit it even further and then I can
also limit it to my from pre-season I
mean that will get me people outside my
face but if I just do my my face and
this is the way I go in when I'm
updating that variety list as I limited
to see New York State and then I look at
the what's been rated in New York State
and how many reviews so then I can order
it also by by not the highest overall
rating I can do it by most reviews and
my state you can get this to search so
now I know um my life State and the most
number of reviews oh look at rest the
existence house of Olympus because even
haven't you grow it for a long time now
so there are are 21 reviews just from
New York State and we should be
tightening maybe three times four times
many 100 reviews so we're encouraging
you to follow through to the end and put
in the review of things that you've
grown
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu